[Music]
no excuses anymore or I start to
optimize my life as many people did
before with technology and apps are
essential for self optimization I'll be
using one of the most popular
nutritional apps yes you it tells me how
many calories my food contains and I
keep note of my daily intake the aim is
to strengthen my resolve to stick to
diet targets that's the theory behind
modern cell optimization or the quantify
itself I also record every step I take
I'm aiming for 10,000 a day in a sports
shop I come across even smarter
technology for 200 euros upwards these
watches use GPS to measure the distance
covered they can also take your pulse we
can try it on you right now sure
what's your resting heart rate around
eighty five four maybe five at rest
yeah that's the normal rate slightly
high but within limits reporte pulse
they do put a lot into the watches you
often need to link to a smartphone close
behind a lot of the technology will
probably migrate from the phones into
the watches and fitness trackers and the
new Bluetooth standard will eventually
mean that you don't always have to have
your smartphone in close proximity that
smartphone direct Ananya with funerals I
record my data in the evening the
nutrition app is the most time intensive
it takes me 15 minutes every day just to
work out how many calories I've consumed
I have a car but walk to work to boost
my daily number of paces I've even got
an app for more efficient sleep it's
supposed to wake me when I'm in a light
sleep phase to ease me into the day more
smoothly it wakes me up every morning
way too early so I won't use it anymore
the quantified self at has been big
business for some time now take
Wunderlist
basically it's a digital diary with a
reminder function 15 million people
swear by it worldwide it's building
based founders sought the platform to
Microsoft for 100 million euros that of
entrepreneur and quantified self and
Mattias a Getty is also looking for a
slice of the digital cake he's just
developed an app that measures a
person's ability to concentrate he is
certain there is a market for optimizing
that with his app you have to calculate
and navigate at the same time people
want approval and firstly that can also
mean digital approval secondly it's not
just about the data there's also the
comparison within the online community
or group like the quantified self group
or on Facebook for the Fitbit community
or whatever somewhere you can obtain
approval and prove yourself providers
and kind of Matthias a Getty goes
jogging twice a week it's my first time
in five years after only four days of
self quantification I'm beginning to
realize just how much discipline and
effort it takes how do we in danger of
driving ourselves crazy we open fire
yeah it's definitely an added stress
factor on the one hand it's satisfying
but on the other it's just another
hamster wheel you're running around it
I feel physically much better now and
I've lost some weight but to be honest I
think quantified self is quite
ridiculous because a guy at my age knows
what's good for him and what's not safe
optimisation at my family's cost for me
it's much more important to spend as
much time as possible with my children
with or without a bit of belly
[Music]